[Music]
and Josh's head is exploding cuz it's
betting time do you mean if there's a
line or the end there's a line now in
the Detroit Miami game well there was a
line all the time there's a whole time
let's go live Sims is field real cocky
and I don't even like it too because
then you leave my paper here face up so
I can turn it over so he turned it over
and then you walked out of the room
don't do that again
don't do that again look that's a Josh
were conspiring again I'm telling you
that he left it up and I literally
verbally out loud one [ __ ] Fenric and
I turned it over I guess I don't even
well I didn't even want it to be there
right I'm being he has not been allowed
in the dock this year there's no
cheating this year okay good the last
three years I can't speak to I don't
understand how I have more money and I
have a better record and I'm cheating
okay Josh let's go the bank oh this week
let's find out yeah Sims
alright guys coming out of week six hi
everybody making a few moves so the bank
accounts through week six seems you are
at minus 1060 Bleacher bucks left go you
are at minus 450 Bleacher bucks people
the big one coming out of week six Sims
you hit your $500 bet all the 49ers on
Monday Night Football
that was overall last week Sims you were
eight in seven left go with six and nine
you still own 25th and where's my 20 I
gave it back to you in the last podcast
pity yes okay and then overall records
for the entire season Sims you are 34 41
and to and left go as 39:36
and to over 500 over 500 I check that
sorry Sims you are 40 to 48 and 2 left
go you are 45 45 into did I was reading
the weak state records my addition was
right I was just reading the wrong page
oh your math we have to like seriously I
think we need to give you a tune I think
we should let him run the document but
my check last night Maddie I used to do
the math I think we need to get Maddie I
do a couple times last year where don't
put him under the belt you dare
all times last year where you didn't bet
the correct amount like you either bet
more or less than I suppose when you and
when you and your fiance go out to eat
who figures out the tip I do do you know
I don't I can do that in my head
I have everything written out here I was
just working a look at the wrong tab
don't worry everything is good
everything is legit if there's one thing
that you guys want to criticize me for
it would be for not eating Jolly
Ranchers as a kid not for my addition my
addition is sound yes okay you can't
wear that shirt on videos great shirt
maybe I want a stroke
how do you feel about these games this
week I feel like there's a lot of
interesting matchups did you find them I
found that there was a lot of teams
where I felt like I knew what they were
facing each other and I bet a little bit
more on a bunch more games this week
what about you um
I really only felt confident in betting
two games really just as would the
spread themselves yeah yeah I did there
was only to where I was like okay I feel
good about these to your spreads did
they end up looking like the actual
lines again they were they were
let's see Josh has seen them they were
pretty IV I went back and looked at your
spreads last week you almost nailed
Texans bills that one ended up being
2013 you predicted 21:30 night but right
you had a few they were close yeah
there's there's I'm pretty on point what
about this week of football in general I
feel like like I think looking at the
games
I think Patriots Bears is gonna be a
great matchup I think Panthers Eagles is
gonna be a great matchup
I think Vikings Jets could be a good
matchup in New York I think Saints
Ravens is a phenomenal matchup and I
think Cowboys Washington and Bengals
Chiefs like I think there's six or seven
real even team yes yeah Bucs Browns I
think that's got a chance to have be a
fun football very fun you know Dolphins
Lions you know second in a row dolphins
are facing a team coming off a bye in
Miami right exactly right you know yeah
I hear you
you know also map Patricia's been able
to look at how New England
did them I also go it's Brock Osweiler I
don't go to the game right to exercise
oh you guys ready make some pics yes no
way guarding off with Thursday night
football the Denver Broncos on the road
visiting the Arizona Cardinals spreads
all my stuff today spread in this game
is Denver - one and a half left go we'll
go - we can't be the green podcast if
you're gonna just waste trees do they
make like bamboo paper it's still
breaking down a tree you're still
wasting with that or throw down paper
baking down a tree but you're still
wasting mortal resources I'm a tactile
learner I need to touch it so I don't
know what to do now that's the [ __ ]
it's early this all day I'm not
retaining anything oh you're not okay no
then everybody don't listen to the left
coast locks their [ __ ] Birds come on
let's go the injuries in your pic okay
injuries out for Denver they're starting
tackle Jared velde are out again like
third week in a row
Ronald Leary out torn Achilles Shane ray
not playing pacman Jones not playing
yeah out for the Cardinals their line is
banged up yeah I you potty is out Jeremy
vu Unova CH is out of backup guards and
I got a little inside information I was
texting with Justin pew he has a broken
hand and he says I'm going to try and
play with it I'm not sure how the pains
gonna do and all I know is like he sent
me a picture of his cast and it kind of
goes over the fingers I it's gonna be
hard taking on you'll Peck oh right in
your face without a doubt I mean if I'm
Petco I'm just gonna attack that ledge
hammer his hand till I text someone said
at least you can't get cold for a
holding tray Boston is out for safety
and Pew is questionable but I know he's
going to try and go the opening line was
Broncos - one and a half we're getting
it at one and a half I am taking the
Cardinals for $50 good one Josh here is
why I'm wrong last 10 Thursday's the
Broncos are eight and two straight up
and against the spread they've been good
on Thursday I was there for one of them
the other reason I'm wrong look Von
Miller called out the whole [ __ ] team
and said we're getting our best this
week
they just let up 200 yards to the Todd
Gurley they're gonna feel
really upset all that at the same point
the reason I'm right is Von Miller just
called out the Cardinals and said we're
gonna beat their ass sure and I honestly
look at the Cardinals and this is a
Cardinals team that hosted the Bears and
almost beat him this is a Cardinals team
that was kind of slugfest with a few
teams Broncos are one for and one
against the spread on the season second
worst in the NFL Cardinals at home
against AFC teams the last 10 games 9
and 1 5 for 1 against the spread I think
that this might be the David Johnson
game and I look at this Cardinals team
and I think that I think that you can't
just say Denver's back against the wall
because I think Arizona's backs against
the wall too so I'm going $50 on the
home team here yeah ok that's cool
all right I'm going $50 on the Broncos
okay it's not gonna be a David Johnson
game with all the offensive line issues
you just talked about yeah I think it's
more of a David Johnson I think they're
gonna get them in the past okay okay and
listen I worry about the Broncos defense
sir there's the two worst rushing
defenses in the sport but the biggest
thing to me I think more than anything
is the Broncos can actually run the
football the Broncos are pretty good
running football team and you're gonna
everyone's gonna get to see Lindsey
again and do all that let go it's a
tough one I do real coin fitted as a
coin flip I'm going Broncos to win the
game 24 17 I think at the end of the day
to the Broncos are just a better
football team I think they have more
better players I do think with Vance
Joseph you know he is the first guy on
the real hot seat like Steve Wilkes is
not in the hot seat even though he's
like the saying like oh we got all play
for our jobs yeah he just signed a new
contract he just got there they're not
gonna fire him in the middle of the
season now bands Joseph's ass might get
fired in two weeks and in the bye week
if they don't straighten their show up
but so you have faith in Vince Joseph
rallying the troops and turning it
around no but I had faith in the bond
Miller aspect of it and just that they
have at least some star players who have
been around winning before that they
might be able to you know hey Case
Keenum was in the NFC Championship game
Bob Miller of course won a Super Bowl
he's been to two Super Bowls since he's
been there he was hurt from one of them
I know that Chris Harris jr. so I'm just
gonna say they kind of win a ugly 24 17
game but
$50.00 yes I'm not going like own crap
going hard on bad teams
all right guys moving on to Sunday 9:30
in the morning
is it they're finally giving us some
warning we got some morning football
here totally forgot there was a London
game this week three in a row man I
totally forgot like last week last week
Chargers Titans and next week is
Philadelphia Jacksonville yes so the
three and 310 that's the game I wanted
them to send me to London well I'm just
disappointed they're wasting that game
on London I well I'm more upset because
we feel Jacksonville owns London yeah
that's why I'm nervous as Garry's fan
yeah they're so used to going anyway
next week's breakdowns 3 and 3 Titans
and the 4 and to LA Chargers in London
Wembley Stadium left go we'll go to you
first for the injuries and then we'll go
over to Sims for the breakdown did not
practice on Wednesday for the Titans
guard Quinton Spain so they continue to
get beaten up even though they've he
came out of the game last week yeah
Derek Morgan and will Compton both did
not practice on Wednesdays for the
Chargers obviously Joey Bosa is still
out Kaiser white missed practice ok and
limited in practice Travis Benjamin is
back to practicing but in a limited time
ok and their kicker Caleb Sturgis was
limited in practice as well right
alright I think the biggest thing here
is I expect the Titans to give their
best effort that was you know listen
Mike Vrabel Dean Pease
you know Lafleur there got to be
embarrassed by everything about last
week it was a disaster so I don't care
what you say you know what you think
about the team you're gonna get the
Titans best hundred percent effort in
this football game because they're
they've been crapped on all week by
their coaches their coaches are feeling
the you know the pressure of that type
of performance to I think the big thing
I look at is like this the Chargers
defense has really turned the corner the
last few weeks in my eyes I don't we
talked about it the other day left go
and I just don't see where the Titans
offense can truly take advantage of the
Chargers defense now vice versa
I still have respect for this Titans
defense and there's things they can do
on that side of the ball but damn the
Chargers offense you know I put it up
there really honing all
whoa what's what's what do you really
stop you take away Gordon you let rivers
go for wide recievers Gordon Eckler kill
you exactly right it's just it's a
really and it's a good scheme and they
have old school running like there's a
reason we thought they were Super Bowl
contains a clear eye there's a reason we
thought the Titans were I'm really mad I
didn't go Saints Chargers I really felt
he was gonna set up for this drew brees
there's his old team Super Bowl and I
went with the Steelers instead but
either way okay I am going $50 on the
Los Angeles chargers why only 50 oh yes
I'm afraid of London I am I mean
[Music]
yeah I'll tell you what I thought with
all the with all the fan issues maybe
they move the Chargers to London I mean
hey at the end of the day it's like what
is that a 10 hour time difference
they've been practicing in Cleveland all
week they stay together it's is it it's
just weird
it's just that's a weird hard thing to
get it that's all that's where I just I
didn't want to go hard on it I'm picking
the Chargers to win 27 to 17 the London
factor and the ass-whoopin the Titans
received last week or the thing that
scared me I am putting a hundred and
fifty on the Chargers and this is
definitely gonna be a left go lock just
so you know
[Music]
you sound like you're from London I
always wonder what the audio listeners
think when we don't talk for like 15
seconds during that song of a room just
dancing the whole time
so my question might not just rub it in
this week yes my answer defend human
about your big concern is I'm just
worried about the Titans getting their
ass kicked and coming back before that
ass-kicking yeah they lost to Buffalo
yeah so that wasn't enough to motivate
them I don't know if this is gonna
motivate them either as well valid point
let go so the reason that I'm wrong that
I don't think maybe the Chargers cover
is since Mariota is rookie year
Tennessee as a six point or more
underdog for and for mm which is like to
be a six point underdog and to win half
your games is pretty damn impressive
four and four again saves 104 and four
versus to spread enhanced radar yes um I
always think of you with the six and a
half and two and a half is that your six
and a half and two and a half four where
there in Vegas what do they call it you
call it like the like everyone goes oh
there's something fishy about yeah
they're just not that confident I
learned that from Coco alright so
remember what I said last week about
London teams when you're the favorite
you win and that's what the Seahawks did
sixteen five and one straight up when
you're the favorite in London 14 and
eight against the spread so the favorite
typically covers more right now the
Chargers their last 15 games is six or
more point favorites
yeah 15 and oh that's pretty impressive
it's 8 and 7 against the spread but 15
and oh just straight up
Tennessee has never played in London
before Rivers faced Brees in London back
in 2008 and lost a shootout 37 to 32
yeah I do like my quarterback having
played in London before and having had
success there if you see it you can
execute it more the Chargers since the
titan-2 chargers against the Titans
since the Titans move to Tennessee
eight oh and one against the spread
eight and one straight up right so
Phillip Rivers you know and the Chargers
against the Titans they have a lot of
success I look at this team and I go yes
Titans are gonna like hopefully gonna
bounce back and odds are but you know
when you have a game where you get
destroyed yeah and instead of being able
to focus on the game plan and motivation
you're also thinking about traveling
across the country and then also I think
when you've had a lot of success and
then you go against the country like the
Chargers the big topic that they're
talking about right now is why aren't
our fans showing up yeah right and so
the good thing is is they go to a place
where they might have more fan base in
in London than they do here in the
States
I just think that when a team's clicking
and then you go to London you keep
clicking and I don't know if it's great
for you I don't know I I really like the
Chargers in this game yeah I hear you I
mean I if this was if this was in the
States
I might have picked another touchdown on
top of that mmm I mean like 3417
something like that
I just feel we I mean I just thought
about them as players and going like
okay you're used to West Coast time okay
now you've gone to Cleveland still East
Coast
Cleveland's east coast right I think
about what wins and losses like this
Chicago you know they had that whole
game last week where they were the
better team right but there was nothing
about Tennessee's last two games where I
go you know what they just got a bad
bounce right they got destroyed yeah and
and the Chargers are a team that we had
a high expectations for they're
executing at a super high level and I
think that those continue when you're
when you have to travel all right guys
next game here starting off the one
o'clock slate and AFC South matchup both
these teams three and three Houston
visiting Jacksonville this bread in this
game is Jacksonville -5 left go give us
the injuries and we'll go to Sims first
for the breakdown so this line started
off at minus four and a half and then so
more of the money is going on
Jacksonville right now injuries Houston
Zack Fulton their offensive lineman did
not practice and Aaron Colvin didn't
practice there a slot corner both them
with ankle injuries Jacksonville for net
and Yeldon did not practice yeah I know
it looks like they might miss some time
coleus Campbell missed time after he
walked off in that game with an ankle
injury and DJ Hayden didn't practice
with a toe injury yeah yeah that's the
layest and the running backs are the ski
everyone's there especially against a
Houston team with a really good D line
very very interesting matchup two of my
favorite teams to watch just because of
the physical nature in which they play I
guess I were I worry about the Texans
o-line in this game even before Zack
Fulton being on the injury list because
the Texans o-line has passed protection
issues there's no other way to say that
and guess who will be foaming at the
mouth the Jacksonville Jaguars I mean I
got to think they bounced back if
there's a team that bounced back a
little they're going home they've been
embarrassed for two weeks in a row to
row that's one thing national television
right and it's one thing to be
embarrassed by the Kansas City Chiefs
it's another thing to just be physically
whooped into the ground in the fourth
quarter against the Dallas Cowboys we're
like you're bleeding and then they just
like took a machete and we're like
pretty more so I I guess I guess I look
at it like this I worry about the Jags
because the Jags are having offensive
line issues like you said running back
issues and their team is built to play
defense and play through the run game
and keep Blake bortles in second and six
and second and five then the boots are
there the screens are there and then the
occasional shot I do think this Titans I
mean Texas defense is getting better and
you know if there's a weakness to the
Jacksonville Jaguars it is still that
you can run the ball on Jacksonville and
Texans are a decent running football
team they are not bad I think okay I'm
gonna bet $50 on the Houston Texans in
this football game yeah yeah
I am I just don't have enough faith that
the Jacksonville Jaguars can win this
game by more than five points they're
not just gonna you know physically whoop
the Houston Texans and we know this
Texas d-line can be pretty brutal
I'm the Jags win the game but 16 to 13
ugly defensive struggle hmm that's a
good point
another thing for you the Texans they're
less they're either three now but
they're one and two against the spread
right I'm gonna put a hundred and fifty
dollars on the Jacksonville Jaguars here
I might be my new favorite one Sims I
very much disagree with you I wouldn't
mind well I I think I say overtaking
your Raven one oh good that's a better
voice yeah it really is here are the
reasons why I really like the Jaguars
last year the Jaguars swept the Texans
to a No and they outscored them 74 to 14
okay what the Titans I might have to do
another chart what the Titans are - the
Jaguars the Jaguars are - the Texans
because if you think about it the Texans
want to be fast and spread it out and
win man-to-man matchups and you can't
win man-to-man matchups against
Jacksonville and you're not gonna outrun
them before the count the first game
from last year ok and did did Watson
even play in the second matchup I'm just
saying I don't think he did in the last
that's all I'm saying I get it I get it
yeah the Texans last 10 games right
there 1 in 9 against the spread move the
jaguars logic telling me it's gonna
change the Jaguars last eight home games
yeah they're 7 & 1
they're 6 & 2 against the spread and I
looked at the Texans on the road they're
1 & 2 on the road they lost at Tennessee
they lost at New England their only win
was that game they almost blew against
the Colts right where they kind of
played really sloppy at the end there
and Jacksonville at home they beat the
Patriots they they lost to that one game
against the Titans and they blew out the
Jets so they beat the Jets by 19 they
beat the Patriots by 11 the Texans are
coming off of a super sloppy win over
the bills where they didn't look that
great I was hoping to see deshaun Watson
kind of continue that run after the
Cowboys and all that stuff and it wasn't
what I hoped for and now they're going
on the road and the jaguars not only get
embarrassed on national television in
their worst defensive performance that i
can remember since this team started to
get together but there's memes about
Jalen Ramsey sitting there and dealing
with their quarterback is there oh like
there's a picture of Jalen Rams to get
that Josh and I were laughing got sent
to us a
times on instance so many people said to
us it's him just sitting on the bench
and it's when you realize what was the
mean I think it's when you've realized
you've talked [ __ ] about every
quarterback in the league and then Blake
bortles is your quarterback yes
and and so my thing is I think this is a
very good Blake bortles game yeah I
think they're bringing out the boots I
think the I think that he performs
really well this game yeah I just think
this is a team that is we need to kill
people and this is a Houston team right
now that has a little bit of false hope
it's going 150 yeah 150 on Jacksonville
yours makes sense because I'm sitting
there and I'm going man like how the
hell are they gonna score if they don't
have yelled and they don't have Fernet
yeah I just think it'll be an ugly game
that's all I think at the end of the day
I do think I mean you're you know the
Jags are the better team there are at
home they're gonna be super motivated
definitely I just think it'll be closer
than five
all right guys next game on the one
o'clock slate here the 3 & 2 Carolina
Panthers on the road visiting the 3 & 3
Philadelphia Eagles temperatures in
Philly on Sunday 50 is the high 35 is
the low cloudy in the skies spread in
this game is Philadelphia what was the
weather in Jacksonville 74 was the
high-end victory no I didn't check the
humidity I'm supposed to be in London
London what do you think I have this all
in my head just know you're supposed to
do your job if I'm ready to establish to
is the weather guys spread in this game
is Philadelphia minus 4 and a half left
go we'll go to you first for the echo
this actually started off as Eagles
minus 3 and a half which is interesting
did it really yeah Carolina Greg Olsen
Dante Jackson limited at practice Dante
Jackson with a groin Philadelphia did
not practice Lane Johnson ankle Darren
Sproles hamstring and then who's going
first here you are ok so I look at this
game and first thing that jumped out to
me is I really want about the Panthers
but it is the Eagles at home yeah Eagles
at home since Doug Peterson took over
they are 15 and 4 straight up now
Carolina on the road their last four
games oh and four straight up and
against the spread right
last year the Eagles as three-point
underdogs went into Carolina in what it
was right before thereby in what I
thought was the season defining game for
the Eagles
it was Nigel Brad UM's best game as an
eagle he had a huge little third and
long stop right at the line or right at
the first down marker he was all over
the place he was hidden cam newton they
did a pretty good job of limiting
Christian McCaffrey and they won that
game 28 to 23 I am putting a hundred and
fifty dollars on Carolina plus four and
a half the Eagles last five games at
home while they are 15 and four at home
their last five their one in four
against the Sprint I am still very
concerned about the offensive line for
the Philadelphia yes get you I find
Jason Peters leaving most games I find
Lane Johnson if he misses it's a huge
huge issue and while I did like the
Eagles offense against the Giants it was
very reliant on slants and one-on-one
matchups and it felt very simple to me
yeah the Jordan Matthew slants like if
the Eagles had to punt back after one of
those times I thought that Eagles Giants
game could have been very close sure and
I think Carolina coming into this game
started off sleepwalking against
Washington and I think they're gonna be
getting the Ron Rivera push right um
yeah I think that this is a close game
that I think the Eagles could win but I
think four and a half it's too many
points yeah to me this is a field goal
game or a Panthers upset yeah III hear
you there a lot of good points I guess I
would look I look at it like this they
match up very evenly they really did a
super both about being big and physical
up front that's really where they get
their advantages most weak they just go
well we're bigger up front on both sides
of the ball and we're gonna win that and
I know you think Fletcher Cox could have
a huge impact with how weak the Carolina
interior Alliance I do and I think
that's what I think ultimately that's
what does scare me for Carolina you know
I think the thing that I look at more
than anything is
I have a hard time believing that
Carolina will run the ball on the
Philadelphia Eagles and that defense and
okay now we got to throw the ball maybe
a little bit more than we want to and as
long as our man Jim Schwartz doesn't
become Jimmy meathead and just play
again he didn't blitz last week
okay make the team execute I got a tweet
today from someone in Philadelphia that
said I'm listening to sports talk radio
and they're saying that the Eagles have
to blitz more now they need to look and
I know there's a few people up and we're
the only people that are looking but
they need to look at all the big plays
the Eagles have led up this season have
basically come against the Blitz then
your defense is talented enough up front
if you can play zone coverage and mix up
coverages and make the quarterback just
Pat the ball once or twice eventually
somebody's gonna hit them and the balls
gonna fly in the air or he's gonna get
hit as he's thrown it's gonna be an
incompletion you still have that type of
diva as a line and you can keep fresh
bodies flying through Philadelphia come
on jaylen Mills ain't that good don't
blitz and leave him in a vulnerable
position just don't forget that point
going forward then I look at the other
side of the ball and just go yeah you're
mean you're right like the Eagles are
simple on offense there they are
it's a simple scheme people have
overestimated what they do the Eagles
became really good last year when the
run game got going and then teams were
like damn they are gonna physically beat
us into the ground and then it makes our
pass game better and I don't I have a
hard time thinking you're just gonna
physically beat them into the ground but
I'll say this if Carolina has a little
problem with their run defense its edge
runs and I always complain the Eagles
don't run the ball up the middle enough
cuz they like to run the ball on the
edge but the Cowboys were very close to
breaking big runs on that Carolina
defense on the edge the Atlanta Falcons
remember we talked about weren't having
Coleman between the garden tackle tackle
and tight end all game long because they
get in those you know double three
techniques where the both linebackers
are inside and then Kuechly and then
gets stuck inside and they can't get out
so that's the advantage to me I know
you're waiting on me to make my pick I
like you and going with the Carolina
Panthers yeah I just
four and a half feels like a lot too
much
I like Eagles though don't you dare eat
that eagle you little Carolina pain yeah
no I think this is a I think this is
gonna be a great game but I'm like you
where it's taking the Eagles to win 23
20 how much you bettin and I'm betting
$50 and I not say that sorry $50 on the
Carolina Panthers but yeah I think this
is a tough hard-fought physical football
team that both are very close I just
like your defense being able to make
them a little bit one-dimensional and I
think you'll be able to run the ball
enough and they don't do enough creative
stuff on the back end of their defense
that weren't when still have a few good
throws and yeah the ball that's my
concern with the Eagles right now is
it's pound run and then Hertz or
Matthews or Alshon on like a like a
slant yeah and get it and let's keep it
going and for Carolina I look at this
offense for Carolina and I just worry
about Cam Newton against this defense
right because I don't really think that
when you look at the teams they face
thus far the Eagles have not faced
really a mobile quarterback yet yes and
when they faced a little one in Mariota
he was able to have a little bit of
success right but I just think I know
that the Eagles have ten days to prepare
I just think there's also you faced the
Giants and you get a little cocky your
defense haven't faced Eli and then here
comes cam yeah I don't know if there's a
bigger difference between two
quarterbacks than having faced Eli then
coming back and facing camera right yeah
yeah you're right and you know we made
the point too but you started off with
the Fletcher Cox thing and those the
interior part of a lion pass protecting
Carolina I have a hard time thinking
they win that much matchup against
Philly to where we can stop the run now
they have to throw too much and I just
as much as I love cam and his ability to
stand and I just think they're gonna be
around of a little too much all right
guys one o'clock here in the New York
area the Minnesota Vikings three two and
one visiting the New York Jets at three
and three high for this game is 49
degrees low as 34 it's finally fall in
New York I assume you're happy about
that extremely spread in this game
Minnesota minus three left go give us
the injuries and then we'll go to Sims
first for the breakdown so did not
practice for Minnesota this week Lynn or
on Wednesday by the way we record this
Thursday so I don't get Thursday
practice reports yet Linville Joseph did
not practice ankle knee and shoulder sin
dejó didn't practice join
Rylee reef left tackle foot did not
practice Dalvin cook full practice fo
prac Dalvin cook is back yep nine people
did not practice for the Jets these are
some of the big names that did not
practice yeah
Isaiah Crowell foot robbie anderson
hamstring don't like when speed guys
have hamstring issues quincy anoon wa
ankle he's out yeah
triangle right terrelle pryor groin
Leonard Williams back yeah Tremaine
Johnson quad Buster screen concussion is
the only game all week the injuries
truly played a factor in my like
absolutely game 100% because they're
about to go battle it out with Minnesota
where you're gonna be more injured by
the end of the game yeah most likely and
what we also know what are the jet the
Jets right now what they're doing is
they're winning through the run game I
mean that's what they're doing they're
they're run they're winning through the
run game which has been very impressive
I just have a hard time thing and
they're gonna dominate the line of
scrimmage against Minnesota's d line
it's been pretty good this year their
run defense has actually been better
this year than last year then you add to
the weapons that are a little banged up
no Quincy and nuna is a big deal for the
Jets and Robbie Anderson that not full
speed it gets a defense that likes to
put eight people with the line of
scrimmage a lot and now have no threat
of a guy that can really fly by them
that's that stinks I'm so mad our man
Mike Hughes got hurt but it's not gonna
be a killer for the Minnesota Vikings
they still have enough secondary guys
they're you know I look at the other
side of the ball the Minnesota Vikings
you know hey Kirk Cousins can throw the
football we know that they've been doing
it without a run game and now that
Dalvin cook is back into the fold here I
think that gives them a little something
more they showed some success in running
the football last week against the
Arizona Cardinals and I know that's not
saying a lot cuz Arizona's run defense
stinks but I have a little more faith in
it I guess then I did two three weeks
ago that they can be balanced my big
thing is this the Minnesota Vikings are
a veteran battle-tested football team
and the Jets are still young and new in
my eyes of course with the young
quarterback but just not experienced at
winning these type of battle-tested
football games so I am going fifty
dollars on the Viking
assemble Vikings
we shall overtake the tri-state area we
will bring all our ships and toothless
the dragon as well they have no chance
I love toothless hello it's one of my
favorite cartoons you ever seen that
that movie How to Train Your Dragon
seriously no I haven't yeah you really
need to like you know like Despicable Me
is really good yeah have you seen that
yes okay how to train your dragons
better than Ace Ventura pet detective
when nature [ __ ] calls like that's
how yes yeah really good eye her out of
touch with our demo you have children
okay you are you don't understand I
can't he was gonna try to make up some
bullcrap all right laughs all right so
let me just give the lines demo so the
Jets are the best team in the NFL I
didn't see how to change your jacket sir
I will see you okay the best team in the
NFL against the spread the last two
years at home is the Jets they are nine
and two against the spread that's great
they've beaten the spread the last two
weeks Colts at home before that who do
they beat at home Broncos Broncos yeah
so they've now won back-to-back games
which i think is you know and and wow
everyone all of a sudden is really like
in Sam darn 'old the only thing I'm
gonna say about that game last week yeah
the Colts wide receivers cause more
interceptions for Andrew Luck than
Andrew Luck exactly right it happened
against the Patriots it happened against
the Jets where Luck throws it across the
middle and these receivers like bat it
up in the air Arlen Mac with the screen
pass on the second play of the game so I
thought I was impressed with the Jets
winning that game yeah but man did Sam
have some small short fields the Avery
Williamson interception the Darren Lee
interception just constantly guys
batting it up and it's like let's go 30
yards and Jason Myers went seven for
seven four field goals real real real
goals and are in there now the old field
goal I am putting 150 dollars he's got
them one bit he's the number for him
this week one on Minnesota
- the three everybody gets into your
boats Todd Bowles about Todd bowels of
our ship okay the reason I like the
Vikings is the last ten time the Jets
have faced the NFC they're three and
seven yeah the last 15 times the Vikings
have faced the AFC they're 10 and 5 and
12 and 3 against the spread the Vikings
are a team right now that I think are
going to start clicking I think that the
Jets are a little bit fuel themselves
and I watching the Vikings and all their
dumb dances and stuff back-to-back weeks
of Kirk Cousins having like a really
good shitty dancing dumb anthem it's not
a good is so horrible I think we should
do like he'd dance like a toddler dances
at a wedding when we correct weight when
there's a crowd and like a little girl
gets nervous there was his dance they
were doing now they were say they were
doing the Bernie but like he did the
Bernie on the first wait what is that it
was a bad Bernie that
so do you member the week the movie
weekend he's just yeah so it's supposed
to be like this goes back and he's
swinging it back and forth
Kirk dancing ain't your thing speeches
AMAs next week though I think Josh has
to do the Bernie
since he's Kirk Cousins cousin yeah
another mother that's what the people
want to see I'll do it I think this is
the Vikings are going to start putting
together a little run here and when you
look at their schedule and you look at
the teams that they've faced you realize
wow this team went to Philadelphia and
got the win they went to the Rams and
put up 31 points they went to the
Packers and Kirk Cousins came out in the
fourth quarter they're a team that's not
bad on the road in fact I actually think
they're pretty good in the road I think
the Jets are gonna get a little
comfortable with their third game at
home and I think that they're going man
we held Andrew Luck I think the Vikings
might win this game by 10 okay yeah I
could see that I sir I definitely I mean
I picked the 28 to 10 I don't know if I
said that but I'm going Vikings 28 to 20
x holy [ __ ]
moving on New England the Patriots four
and two on the season heading out on the
road to Chicago to face the Bears at
three and to Chicago on Sunday high is
49 low is 37 spread in this game is new
English
- three left go give us the injuries and
then Simms your breakdown I'd love for
you from now on
- if you could add like wind wind all
right well I got a pull that's a real
thing in that place ten mile an hour
winds coming out of the West maybe three
percent humidity coming out of the east
sunrise seven or nine a.m. on somewhat
on my Chicago favorite stadiums in all
of football pretty especially this time
of the year do you like it even with the
renovations I actually like him more how
come it's more on top of the field it's
like a spaceship on the inside it is
cool if they kept the outside with the
old-school look and I just you know I
I love downtown city stadiums
I love downtown city stadiums and also
that stadium is like on the lake it is
and that's why people don't realize like
it's right up there with Pittsburgh it's
right up there with these places where
it's a little tough to kick yeah and you
got to be able to throw the ball it's
it's really cold the Windy City for a
[ __ ] reason man like those pictures
when it gets cold there make it up they
made the buildings so they could sway in
the wind did you know that oh yeah they
have like a little I was a little boy I
was like damn I feel like I was there
for a Bears game the game the year they
made me cry in the stadium versus the
Bears but yeah I I could feel the the we
were up high on a hotel and they could
feel the thing moving you know it's not
called the Windy City because of the
wind
no called that because of their
politicians oh you know what I do
remember there's a lot there's bull
scrap right I'm going to tell you that
it's still I did windy it is windy it's
right on Lake Michigan alright spread in
this game New England - three left go
injuries and there were Sims
so Marcus cannon did not practice
because of a concussion so we'll have to
wait and see they're starting right
tackle limited for the Chicago Allen
Robinson with a groin Amukamara with a
hamstring did not practice Wednesday
with an ankle Khalil Mack mm-hmm
interesting to wait and see he didn't do
anything in the game last thing I was
wondering what was really wrong with
them I mean he could and he came out a
lot so I knew something was wrong I'm
sorry I didn't mean because you know
please I thought I was it yeah I want
you to go into your pick
yeah so that was the interesting thing
okay this is the first thing I would
start off with the Chicago Bears I got a
lot of respect for this football team
where they're going this is the most
complete football team they have played
this year coming to town
the New England Patriots yes they are
coming and if you look at Chicago yeah
they played the Green Bay Packers week
one but Seattle Arizona Tampa Miami
Dolphins the point nobody is really
complete as they are on both sides my
other big point would be this New
England gets two weeks of preparation
for this game I mean that's what people
are forgetting I mean it's two weeks of
preparation do you know what I mean by
that
I don't same offense I was thinking that
on the train oh the rules are gonna be
still the same except Bill's gonna go
you know the rules we had last week I'm
gonna add a few more wrinkles because we
shouldn't have a huge big learning curve
here naked right it's the same was
thinking that so that aspect of it it
would be concerning to me for the
Chicago Bears
I really think New England's offense has
got it going from that from that with
the run game past game you know the the
Bears as much as I like their defense
they do need that pass rush from a
Khalil Mack and not having him out there
is a huge deal for me you saw that Brock
Osweiler got to throw the ball around
the field last week against that Bears
defense who doesn't love to play
man-to-man they play it but they don't
want to really play it and make it their
game and that could be an issue when you
play a New England and Tommy Boy cos
Tommy will pick apart his own as good as
anybody so I look at that and then I go
ok you know the Bears offense hey it's
got some explosive elements I think that
anytime we're in an obvious passing
situation guys like tarik Cohen are
going to be doubled like we saw last
week with Tyree kill at certain times
when they get down in the red zone I'm
not sure who they well Tariq will be one
of the guys they double I don't know who
the other guy they will double off of
that that'll be the interesting thing
that I'll watch or but at the end of the
day I gotta go with the New England
Patriots for $600
yeah Tommy boys coming to Chicago okay
park your car in the Chicago yard Billy
and Tommy are coming there's nothing he
could do it not even Mike Ditka and the
hurricane Ditka can deal with Billa
checks sorry
put your polish sausages away sorry $600
pictures I did not see that yeah yeah I
was winking at him too because you
weren't looking and I was like heaters
we got you the whole break you didn't
even know this is coming 6:21
Patriots win let's go biggest bears fan
ever I am betting $100 on Chicago last
three $700 swinging bears bears bears
bears best pants pants best yes here's
why I'm wrong in Simms is right the last
15 games for the Patriots they're 12 and
3 against the spread right okay just
want you to know though that they
haven't been beating the spread lately
okay Tom Brady has never lost to the
Bears he's four no three and one against
the spread last time they went to
Chicago what happened you member that
game no who's this no game and they won
like what year was this like how many
years ago was a while ago this is Snowie
game I know that and they put up like it
was like fifty to five it was like
disgusting I think I do remember here's
why I like the Bears since first of all
the Patriots on the road this season
right what's their record Sims Patriots
on the road this yeah I'll let you look
it up and find it out for yourself
they've lost two on the road and what's
that how many would they want um none
because they haven't been on there since
Detroit interesting loss to Detroit and
Jackson and they have been able to over
and they've they've looked so good at
home better as a go yeah I get it
they're just Owen two on the road
straight I've been against the spread
interesting since 2016 the Bears as a
home underdog what do you think they are
against the spread they've played 11
games Oh eight and three nine one and
one Oh Chicago at home is one of my
favorite bets to make because the grass
tall the wind is strong only if the
Patriots cared about it being slow
they're the slower team in this matchup
they're actually like grow at Chicago so
and I found this on reddit from a user
parks three one eight always about the
grass city who looked up Tom Brady
versus a Vic Fangio defense I was there
for one of them and New England he said
he went back in the last ten years and
he could only find one when the 49ers
played in New England 2012 Sunday night
and the 49ers jumped out to a huge lead
and then the New England Patriots
stormed back and then Kaepernick made a
few big throws to win the game on one of
the last drives of the game Patriots
lost 41 to 34 Tom Brady through 64
passes most of his yards and damage done
was in the fourth quarter he was sacked
three times he threw one touchdown two
interceptions with a quarterback rating
of 68 point nine yeah I understand that
they just made steps in that game huh
the Patriots are coming off of a game
where I know that they're gonna be
motivated right but they beat an
undefeated Chiefs team and they're on
Sunday Night Football and I have to
think that some of the players and the
Patriots are human absolutely not some
of the robots especially the ones on
defense is Lourdes Lourdes okay so
here's a thing I don't think that Brady
takes a step back I don't think that
grant takes a step back but I do think
that the Josh Gordon's of the world I
think the young offensive lineman's of
the world
I think the Sony michelle's of the world
I don't think James White will but I
think that Trey flowers of the world the
guys that I saw Hootin and Hollerin and
all that stuff yeah I also think that if
there's one team that's gonna be super
motivated this week it's the frickin
Bears right because they go in there
after a buy and lay an egg in the
dolphins where they were the better team
for the whole game I thought try Biscay
played pretty well in that game yeah I
thought Jordan Howard and tarik Cohen I
thought what about our team I thought
that who's the the speedy wide receiver
Gabriel
Taylor Gabriel it continues to be a
point I think the Bears
it's a beautiful coming back
super motivated team coming off a high
win I'm getting a home team with three
points and I know it's the Patriots I
just thought three points was a little
low for me
hey $600 $600 I'm taking a bit I see
1012 match up because I was working in
New England Tom is better now than he
was in 2012 oh I know
and that 49ers team oh my god oh that
was the most overrated coach ever yeah
the most talent he had a really talented
that's team in football like almost
every year he was there I mean they were
like they were like the all when they
walked on the field in pregame you're
like whoa like Navarro Bowman and
Patrick Willis and Justin Smith and
Dashon Goldson and Whitner and and alden
Smith before all the crowd happily
miners were so good that like two or
three years in a row two or three years
in a row they drafted a kid out of
college in the first three rounds that
suffered like a debilitating knee injury
and everyone went there a deep enough
they can handle that you know what I
mean I do yes I know they screwed up by
doing that yes like the watch amber I'm
curious this is a $700 swing game if
Josh vendrick had to pick one of these
who would you go I'd go with the
Patriots would you I don't bet against
New England
I feel really got mushed
all right guys moving on next game in
the one o'clock slate here the 2 & 4
Buffalo Bills on the road good think
there's going a little higher than I was
shocked and I saw three visiting the one
in five Indianapolis Colts I think it's
a trap I've been going out of my way not
to look at lines during the week like I
do really smart I don't want to be know
so yeah just in case you're curious the
weather in Indianapolis on Sunday it's a
it's a doll that's why I said just in
case you're curious yeah it's a dome
doesn't matter Joey 51 degrees is the
high 34 is the low 56 percent humidity
so shouldn't be an issue for the bills
walking off the bus spread in this game
Indianapolis minus seven left go give us
the injuries and your pick alright so
Josh Allen is out for Buffalo Trent
Murphy it was limited in practice with
an ankle it's looking like Derrick
Anderson's going to start this game yeah
I mean he has to he
ass - okay they they you're gonna like
have pickets I did not practice on
Wednesday Ryan grant a wide receiver and
tight end Jack Doyle T Y Hilton is back
he's back right Marcus Marcus hunt also
back um the estonian is back so this is
the first time since 2016 that the colts
are a favorite of six or more points so
it's the first time in two years that
they have in a favorite like this and it
makes sense I mean the Colts have been
absolutely a mess and they're one in
freakin five I mean this is a team that
I'm seeing fighting tooth and nail on
every game and one of the most
entertaining teams to watch and they're
one in fricken they're like the 49ers of
the AFC I like that yeah yeah they're
like in every game every game you're
like oh they might do it here in the
last Drive and something happens so
Derrick Anderson's last start was in
October of 2016 and I would say that
it's a prevailing notion the NFL that he
was there because Cam Newton liked him
in the room he was brought to Buffalo
because they wanted a similar thing with
Josh Allen in the room and you know
Shaun McDermott goes I like the way that
you worked with Cam yeah we need it like
Josh Allen can't be learning from
Peterman he needs to be learning from
someone but I don't think Derrick
Anderson thought that he was gonna be
playing anytime soon I would think not
and so I think this might be a little
shocking right yeah right I am putting
$100 on the Colts - seven here is why
I'm wrong the Bills have been an
underdog at six or more points in all
six games this year and they've won two
of them yeah so they they're just used
to being in this position yeah
the bills are three and one against the
spread in their last four games right
okay here's why I'm right with Andrew
Luck when they're favored by six or more
points the Colts are 12 and 310 and five
against the spread I will say though in
their last three in this situation there
oh and three against the spread one and
two straight up it's been a different
cold steam lately yeah the Colts have
played four of their last five games on
the road who I remember eyes that there
are a few teams this week the Browns
being one of them the Browns play have
played like four of their six games at
home
the Colts have played four of their six
games on the road and when they're at
home you know they can battle back
against Houston they can really put up
some points against the Bengals it is
back-to-back road games for Buffalo the
last time they had back-to-back road
games the second leg they got they lost
22 to nothing the Green Bay so you know
they got to keep doing the travel I
think that Shawn McDermott will go and
have a good game plan for Andrew Luck
but I think when you're facing and your
luck your game plan works for two and a
half quarters and then he just makes
things happen and I got a think with T Y
Hilton healthy at home I think that
Buffalo wants to keep you in the box
I think Indianapolis gets a few things
deep and I just don't think Derrick
Anderson and this Buffalo offense is
going to be able to put up enough points
to withstand the late Andrew Luck charge
that's why I'm going a hundred on the
coal yeah listen I get you all the way
I'm gonna make this quick okay I'm going
$50 on the Colts going $50 on the Colts
I have just a hard time believing Victor
so just not you know cold everybody I
like to give him carrots carrots I
usually do with my little girl goes
horseback riding are you someone that is
weirded out when the horses lips touch
your hand no not at all animals are fine
humans are gross animals are not good
today there we go right don't you agree
humans are gross animals are not um some
some would you hold a tarantula that's
not an animal it's an insect what the
animal is not a classification well it's
a it's still an insect that's not like a
mammal would you hold a possum I would
ugly as hell but I would hold it yeah
it's gonna be a good experiment for a
podcast yes I love animals you know that
I guess the other thing I look at I mean
yeah but the bills hi and how can their
offense move the ball it's not good
anyways and now you got a guy who hasn't
played football and forever he's just
he's learning a new system but - are the
Colts one of those teams that they might
be able to do it by default I I don't
think so the Colts don't beat themselves
on defense a whole lot they're not it's
been turnovers really yeah it's not
they're not
and not an overly talented defense but
you know
what's-his-name Eber flavourful is I
gotta get that damn name right he they
run a sound defense they're detailed
they don't blow assignments they've had
a few here and there I understand that
they're the Colts and they've been put
in a lot of tough positions
I think the Bills defense will be a real
big pain in the ass for the Colts
certainly I just think Andrew Luck
scores 17 points Derick Anderson
probably throws one dumb interception
maybe it's a pick six either way he's
backed up something like that
I think the Colts won the game 20 49 I
just don't understand how the bills can
really do enough moving the ball I'm not
gonna sit here and go oh yeah the bills
are gonna run all over the Colts I don't
see that happening either the culture
one defense is okay it's not gonna be
like parting of the Red Sea yes so I
just look at it from there I also think
that if I'm the Buffalo Bills yeah and I
watched a few of the Nathan Peterman
interceptions and I'm watching the guys
around him so he had the one where he
rolled out right through it cross field
and I'm just watching LeSean McCoy and
his entire body collapses and you know
that they're sitting there going man
this guy's screwing our season I would
have met then Derick Anderson's gonna
get out there yeah and they're gonna go
maybe this guy is better right and when
they see that it's not gonna be that
much better
I gotta imagine that buffaloes like God
well they're gonna see it's better this
week in practice they're gonna know that
because Derick Anderson can really throw
the ball and he's a big dude so they're
first their first thing is gonna be okay
this guys throwing 40-yard piss missiles
all over the field that's cool look I'm
gonna get out there but it doesn't
matter yeah yeah it really doesn't and
man I had another point but I forgot
that all right guys next game on the one
o'clock slate here the two three and one
Cleveland Browns on the road visiting
the 2 & 3 say that I really works I
really like doing this show yeah it's
fun there's a lot of fun if I'm a Bills
in a Colts fan yeah we might be the only
[ __ ] show that spends eight minutes
on the bills and Colts I know and I'd
ask you I think we might use our value
talking about what everyone else talks
about or what people don't have the
balls to talk about hey I don't fear
motors is the key No Oh Marcus hunt is
this is my guess
this is I gonna say this is AI gonna say
okay first of all nobody is gonna talk
about it for four minutes we out time
them by double anything other thing is
Nathan Peterman I would have a hard time
thinking he's on this roster here much
longer I would really do I think they're
gonna find another third stringer to go
along to backup Derick Anderson I know a
guy
d-ohh you're talking about Sims yeah
well we'll see I don't know about that
but I was just saying they've all up
Dave ball if you read my and if I read
the NFL tea leaves I would go I would
have a heart and I don't know if Nick
Nathan Peterman is in danger of being
out of the NFL really he really is and I
don't not proud to say that I'm just
saying we talked it and kept it real
that would be a bother a worry they said
that about Matt Schaub - yeah but at
least Matt Schaub had years of running
the number one offense and football for
top five offense for like five or six
years so that gave him some street cred
all right guys one o'clock on Sunday the
two three and one Cleveland Browns on
the road visiting the 2 & 3 Tampa Bay
Buccaneers it is gonna be a scorcher in
October in Tampa on Sunday what is it
84 degrees Oh 66% humidity I used to
hate those days factor that in yeah what
is this like in our Tampa Bay - 3 is the
spread hoof it just it's a because it
doesn't sound that hot no but you know
you're used to Cleveland weather yes we
get out there and I was always like a
you know of course in northeastern I was
always like maybe a nice fall day today
Sunday and I'd walk out of the hotel the
day the game that gosh it's hot as hell
in humid here we go
so did not practice for Cleveland
Rashard Higgins wide receiver linebacker
Joe sherbert Center JC Treader and EJ
gays the corner was just deemed out ok
did not practice for the Bucs
Vinny curry and Gerald McCoy hmm should
be interesting McCoy it's a calf curry
it's an ankle am I going first or is he
going you go first
this game is uh we're getting to a bunch
of the games where I really don't know
yeah because I don't trust you right so
I'm gonna be betting $50 on Tampa Bay -
three heroes why I'm wrong do it again
you shot no error thank you I was gonna
be like are you kidding me I'm gonna
Viking
it's like the easiest is on every Viking
you shall um I was thinking of like a
hairy boat guy yeah a Viking here's why
I'm wrong for the Browns the Buccaneers
in their last six games it's really good
one in five against the sprin in two and
four straight up her or are you having
confidence now left go I don't think so
also for the Browns they are tied for
the third best in the NFL for and two
against the spread haha yuhu
here's why I like my bucks since Hugh
Jackson took over the Browns now I'm
turning the Sean Connery you're like a
wildling huh it's a little game of
Thrones wildling our Browns are Owen
nine against the NFC under Hugh Jackson
one and eight against the spread also
the Buccaneers in their two home games
this year Philadelphia Pittsburgh have
dropped 54 points Cleveland has played
four home games this year their road
games they lost to the New Orleans
Saints when I don't find that that
impressive because as I mentioned during
that time of the year the Saints always
start slow and really in the end of the
game the Saints did whatever they wanted
against that defense out Kamara Michael
Thomas right there other Road game of
the Browns they allowed 45 points to the
Oakland Raiders right so this is a
Browns team that I think look I don't
think bad teams travel well and I'm not
willing to say Cleveland is a good team
yet
yeah Tampa Bay has played for road games
there two games at home Philadelphia and
the Steelers and I'd argue it was other
than their Saints game the two best
games of the year right
so I look at this Tampa team and I think
it's a home game I think Tampa Bay is a
weird place to play Baker Mayfield is
banged up right now yeah and I think the
Buccaneers offense is going to be able
to throw on the Browns that's why I'm
taking the Bucs but I don't know this
game I'm taking $50 well I feel a lot of
the same way this have the same feelings
as you I do I mean both defenses
are not good so that's the first thing
we have to talk I mean the Browns were
28th in football the Buccaneers are 31st
in football bucket really quick question
before you I'm gonna put my microphone
away yeah when you fire your defensive
coordinator yeah I think it'll be a good
thing at first I'm not saying it'll be a
good thing at the end of the day I'm not
saying long term I'm saying for us
betting all right you get a little bump
wouldn't you let a coordinator go I do
think so yes I do think you get a little
bit of a bump because he's gonna bring a
new energy the team probably was already
losing belief in Mike Smith he's not an
energy guy himself no you're right he's
not to begin with and then you get into
okay the new coach might add something
here or there that the other team isn't
ready for because it's a new coach and
he's gonna do I've been wanting to do
this and been telling Mike Smith to do
this and now I'd like that to be done
hey the Browns the run defense is
horrible their past defense is not good
I don't think the Bucks are gonna take
advantage of their run defense was good
it's falling apart and it is it really
is and the big thing is I do still think
they lack big people in the middle left
go that's one of their biggest issues
you know we've got some good D lineman
they don't have legit run stoppers
that's one issue they have and their
linebackers are not good I don't know
what to say no show bird is not good
Jamie Collins has moments he's better as
an outside linebacker and Christian
Kirksey has been disappointing this year
added to the fact that when they bring
Jabril Peppers down into the box - it's
a waste of time and when it's a pass
they take him out of the game and I'm
known anybody realize that that their
first-round pick from last year comes
out of the game when it's passing
situations okay booming with all that
being said I I watch the Chargers score
on the Browns with lob balls yeah the
the Bucs might be the best lob ball team
in the NFL no doubt about it
jump ball city exactly right and they
pass protect okay - so I don't think
Miles Garrett's going to ruin this
football game coming off the edge or
anything like that and I gotta think
Jameis will be better this week having
played a full game now and having that
underneath his belt they have weapons on
that offense certainly still the Browns
pass defense does not have enough in the
secondary to slow them down and yeah
Baker Baker and that
Brown's offense hey that they can run
the football give that and they gotta
give chub the ball more chubs their best
running back
I like Carlo side I'm not no disrespect
to him but chub does more with less than
any of their backs where I just go man
there's only five yards there and he got
12 and I you know I always look at the
stats and go damn well I don't
understand it every time he touches the
ball it's like a 15-yard gain and then
he doesn't get the ball for like five
series and I just go like what are you
guys watching the game over there if
you're gonna sit here right and wonder
why Hugh Jackson's teams do things that
don't make sense I know that I'm going
to question you I know I hear you're
right exactly right um and how much oh
I'm just going $50 okay
I think the Bucs win this game 31 24 I
and I Yoho Yoho the buyer is late for me
man I used to love Gasparilla everybody
Gasparilla Gasparilla was like yeah say
Nikki knows Gasparilla is Mahdi Grod
Tampa but it's when the Pirates landed
on Tampa and they have a huge boat
parade and you do all that stuff you
throw beads right what time of year
doesn't it in the spring and I used to
have a house
all right go left go showed a Hondo that
was on the water and I would have
parties and we'd have like a barbecue in
my backyard and watch all the boats go
by and it's basically like a parade on
boats and then they get on the road to
do that but man it was a blast miss that
Tampa days those were good all you
shouldn't do that that would be fun a
Chris Sims float for Gus and they get
the pirate ship out you know the pirate
there's a pirate ship in the Tampa Bay
uh a true pirate a bring it through the
street and then at the end for this
though they Brett they actually it's
always parked on the water and then for
this day it gets all decorated up ten
day day is one of those American cities
where I don't even really know anything
about it I just know that a lot of New
Yorkers move down there they have no
support for most of their sports teams
it's it's New York Boston Chicago and
Detroit and they go to Tampa and it's
like the people that are like I don't
really want to live in Miami so I'm
gonna live in exactly it's more of a
chill chill atmosphere compared to the
east coast of Florida like to make you a
merging celebrity back in Tampa Bay I'd
like to reignite
project I thought he was gonna say that
Gasparilla was week eight and you were
gonna start furiously writing down not
to bet on the box next bring I thought
it was a drink no I'd like a Gasparilla
sour all right you guys ready to move on
here yeah let's do it
okay last game of the one o'clock slate
the Detroit Lions at two and three on
the road visiting the Miami Dolphins at
42 I don't know what's coming over here
yeah football is good it's good you guys
thought it was hot in Tampa oh yeah tell
ahamill what's it going 90's high of 87
okay 72 percent humidity 72 we thought
the Bears had problems last week man
Detroit coming to town spread in this
game Detroit - three left go give us the
injuries and we'll go to seem surprised
to see that I was surprised to see that
what were you thinking it was gonna be I
know I didn't know if Detroit would be
favored I guess I didn't know I guess I
thought I might see at Miami by white
one
I was hoping Miami would be favored yeah
so did not practice for the Lions
they're coming off of a bye Theo Riddick
what did not practice limited in
practice Ezequiel Anza and TJ lang Lang
is coming off a concussion two weeks ago
honest it was a shoulder our Ryan
Tannehill is out four defensive linemen
either did not practice or were limited
in practice for the Dolphins I did not
practice Charles Harris Jonathan Woodard
limited in practice cam wake and Andre
Branch both of the knee this is a game
that it's very funny it's another NFC
North team coming off of a bi playing in
hot Miami that is it's interesting I
always think that when one team goes
through it first it opens the eyes for
the other team yeah I think there's some
truth to that so I think for Detroit to
see Chicago down there lay an egg I
think it wakes up Detroit I'm gonna put
$100 on Detroit so I'm going against my
thoughts from last week other reason is
I like Stafford so the reason I'm wrong
the Dolphins are undefeated at home this
year three and oh three you know at home
straight up and against the Sprint
they're facing another team off a bye
the reason I like the Lions their second
best in the NFL right now against the
spread at
one right the last six years after a by
five and one against the spread tied for
the best of the NFL now it is a new
coach I'm gonna steal a little bit of
your luster right here the same way that
you're saying the Patriots are ready for
Matt Nagy's offense because they faced
it yeah Patricia can be ready for the
Dolphins offense
I agree cuz he watched Belichick facing
right I think that Detroit I messed up
my pick they're just keep going sorry
okay um I look at Detroit and I think
that I really think they look at the
Chicago game and they learn from it
I like Detroit and I think Detroit could
end up being a surprise fighting for the
wild-card team I really think they're
presenting themselves in that fashion
and my main point came down to I got a
little bit lucky taking Miami last week
because every ball bounce their way like
for every ball exactly I just don't see
that happening again yeah I think that's
the same thing I feel okay I'm going
opposite of you
I'm going $50 in the Dolphins sorry I
missed it I got you but I know I
couldn't do it to you a little dolphin I
just couldn't feed you to the lion I'm
sorry so we kept you separate I picking
the Lions to win the game 23 21 okay I
am a lot of the reasons you just said I
think my biggest reason is I just am NOT
gonna sit here and have the faith that
the Miami Dolphins and Brock Osweiler
are gonna be able to score 31 points
again I just I don't see that happening
I really don't I think Detroit is a team
that went into the bye week also too
with a little bit of an edge like okay
we got things going but we're still two
and three I don't think that they're
gonna be relaxed by any stretch of the
imagination and by weeks always do scare
me from that standpoint because you get
lazy and sloppy with some of your
techniques and things like that but I
think at the end of the day I just look
at it like that
I had to another point I wanted to make
here but I can't remember what it was
yeah the Dolphins defense been a little
disappointing to me lately too many big
plays too many big plays and I think
that the Lions could take advantage I
exactly right and that's really why I
think it'll be a close football game you
the difference between tell me if I'm
wrong here I'm sorry for I'm sorry
the difference between Chicago
offense right now right troit offense is
I feel like Chicago likes to move their
way down the field and occasionally take
shots Yeah right and Detroit I feel like
it's all shot they want to run the ball
right and then when they throw it right
now it's like our yards yeah we're going
further I mean if a guy like Tate that
breaks a lot of tackle right and Marvin
Jones and Galileo just bombed for us
agreed and I don't think we've really
seen the best of Matthew Stafford yet
either he's really gonna struggle this
year I've never seen Matthew Stafford
miss more you know throws than he has
this year ever ever and I got to think
he's had to reevaluate himself in the
bye week there someone tweeted at me and
they said apparently instead of calling
marques Valdes scantling I was referring
to him as Wilson Valdez Spaulding and
nobody corrected Wilson Valdez Spaulding
is actually marques Valdez gambling you
should call him well thank you Kyle why
that's his 9/8 any say about that game
good okay moving on to the four o'clock
games 405 New Orleans this is one asset
this is this is that may be the game of
the week four and one New Orleans on the
road visiting the four and two Baltimore
Ravens high of 52 in Baltimore on Sunday
spreading this game Ravens - two and a
half left go injuries and then Sims your
breakdown first yeah okay
injuries Ted Ginn did not practice again
the Saints are coming off of a buy the
Bears on the breakdown the beatdown
excuse me the Ravens on the beatdown of
the Titans Alex Lewis guard not didn't
practice Wednesday yeah Brandon Carr
didn't practice with a knee yeah I was
wondering what happened to him in the
game car is and knee Lewis is a neck
okay yeah that's a big one with Lewis I
mean he's a really good guard but if
they can overcome it I'll say that that
was it alright yeah and then pretty
clean injuries they can overcome car -
now because Marlin Humphrey and Justin
Smith are there and they're okay and
this Ravens defense is the real deal
Holyfield I'm mixed I think this is the
game I'm most excited about this weekend
I really am and these are two teams that
greet four o'clock slate I really want
to whoop your butt and you know I keep
you know people got to realize the
Saints are kind of a run first team
right now I know they're awesome at
passing the ball but I especially think
with Mark Ingram back in the fold they
want
to run the ball you're not gonna run on
the Baltimore Ravens a whole lot okay
that's the first thing I would look at
and the Saints defense hey it's it's
certainly gotten better but I'm not
gonna sit here and annoying it anything
special yet at sitting at 18th and
football right and letting almost 300
yards per game in the air and Baltimore
can throw it this year like years past I
would've gotten Baltimore it's not good
enough to take advantage of this bad
past defense they are good enough to pay
do it this year along with the fact that
they can pass protect now I also think
on the other side of the ball you know
with some of what Baltimore does on that
side and some of the creative blitzes
and coverages like Sean Payton's gonna
be prepared for for that and they're
gonna have a few plays where we're gonna
go man we haven't seen Baltimore really
do this or let up these type of plays
but I think when it all comes to a head
for me I just look at it and go it's
Saints coming off a bye again which
scares me Baltimore is a tough place to
play
drew Brees does not throw the ball that
well outside it's a huge factor to me I
mean he didn't throw the ball that well
a few weeks ago in New York yeah and
that to me
plays in the favor of the Baltimore
Ravens I think this game was very close
hard-fought but I'm gonna go with the
Ravens for $50 and I expect them to win
27 to 24
there's no printers that can save you
from the Ravens okay oh he's going
Saints am i or is he the way he took a
breath there because I'm trying to
figure out if I want to give my pick
right away or if I want to do those they
don't tease me
so here is what benefits the Saints okay
what he's laughing at I said tease me
like keep a low here's here are the
advantages of the Saints since 2015 the
Ravens against the NFC four and eight
straight up three and want to get three
eight and one against the spread the
Saints have won four in a row three
straight covers yeah the last eight
years under Sean Payton so not including
2012 when he was kicked out of the
league because of yeah head
issue number was right after a by I went
and did this myself yeah
the Saints are six and two and they
averaged 36 points a game after above
pretty impressive you know why however
their 6a know at home after a body there
Owen - on the run that is why I am
betting $100 on the Ravens here's what
else drew the Ravens are 2 and on home
this year you got it you had a good
Smeagol voice stand okay oh it comes to
bottom I got lost well you lost they
lost they lost it with the pirate and
they went to the Jaguars in Tampa Bay
okay it's gone Ravens are two now at
home this year and straight up at
against the spread and against Buffalo
and Denver in those two games they've
allowed 17 points total at home yeah the
only team that hasn't allowed what a
second half touchdown okay so very
interesting here is the reason the main
reason I'm afraid and I almost went on
New Orleans yeah of the 32 teams the NFL
drew Brees this could be it right has
beaten all of them except for the Ravens
he's Owen four against the Ravens that
scares me because I believe in my heart
this might be the Drew Brees season he
breaks the passing record he's gonna hit
the 500 touchdowns everyone's talking
about how he has not won an MVP yet I'm
afraid of the storyline drew Brees gets
the Baltimore Ravens monkey off his back
he's now beaten every team in the NFL
he's now the all-time leading passer
they go on a run they finished 13 and 3
12 and 4
it's the drew Brees and B for the other
two quarterbacks that have done that
beat all 32 teams I'm gonna go with I'm
not Tom Brady no I'm gonna go with
Peyton Manning you're right about that
and I'm going to go with it has to be a
big quarterback that got traded exactly
it's gonna be really I'm gonna go
Montana nope okay keep going
I mean just keep thinking legends think
it quarterbacks I was gonna say Alex
what's another no legends think about
skews all-time top five or six
quarterbacks that we've done far yes so
I'm really just afraid of the storyline
and I'm afraid of I thought of the
Bengals Ravens game yeah and I thought
about how the Bengals were able to use
their speed to negate all of the
strengths that the Ravens have yeah and
I think about Sean Payton being a really
good OC and I think about getting camara
to the outside and I think about getting
Michael just winning the isolations with
Michael Thomas and I just think though
that the Ravens at home I believe that
both of these teams are Super Bowl
contenders yeah and I always go to the
home team when it's a battle of really
good teams but I could totally see the
Drew Brees storyline but outside yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna be I'm really I'm
really pumping this this is gonna be a
really interesting with three four
o'clock games yeah it's this Baltimore
New Orleans yeah Washington Dallas and
Rams Niners I love all of that's a
really good one all right guys one
second just oh my god first of all I
seriously need someone to get me
Chipotle I'm so hungry
okay I'm going to die I'll work on it
I'm gonna die on the podcast like die
like the Ravens coming to he's floating
around cuz he sees that I'm hungry he
knows I might kill over other thing is I
before he was going see look he's there
he knows that I'm about to keel over the
other thing is this Saints just real
quick this interesting little schedule
they got coming up did you check that
out I've been talking about it since the
preseason god this is the part of the
Saints schedule where they needed to
start off in the past yeah and this is
the reason why before the year I didn't
have them winning the south because
they're going at Baltimore at Minnesota
home against the Rams at the bengals
home against the Eagles yeah that is
some that's the truth right there we're
gonna know all about the Saints when
this stretch is over I feel very similar
to what we're going experience from the
Rams right now Rams are going in the
third stretch of an at road game against
the Niners and then facing Aaron Rodgers
after a bye yeah and then at the Saints
so the Rams have a nice little stretch
to
alright guys 425 here on Sunday the
Dallas Cowboys three and three on the
road visiting Washington at three and
two hi in Washington 55 degrees partly
cloudy in the skies spread in this game
is Washington - two left go injuries in
your pic first so likely out Tavon
Austin Shawn Lee is back and practicing
in a limited fashion he could be back
this week did not practice for
Washington Adrian Peterson Jameson
Crowder Paul Richardson and am I going
first
yes okay I looked at this game and I had
talked about some of the trends on
Monday right the Cowboys have been
owning this series so the reason that I
would want to think Washington Dallas is
Owen three on the road this season yeah
Dallas is also gone win-loss win-loss
win loss or lost win lost win and then
they won so it would be a loss and it's
the opposite for Washington
they've gone win loss win loss win so
they're due to lose so then they're both
little is okay then that actually makes
me feel better about this that that was
some some nonsense from us right there
Dallas has three games on the road this
year yeah 16 points 13 points 8 points
yeah a little scary right I am putting a
hundred and fifty dollars on Dallas you
know what I saw when I saw these trance
yeah Dallas last seven times they faced
Washington they've won 6-5 and two
against the spread since 2017 the
Cowboys against the NFC East six and one
against the spread the last six games
for Washington against the NFC East one
in five so this is the bottom of the NFC
East barrel against the team that's
winning a lot in the NFC East they beat
Washington last year in a pretty muddy
year by a combined score of 71 to 33
also I went back and added up the last
five road games for Dallas in Washington
they've scored 33 27 1944 24 Wow Dallas
has
Washington's number it happens they go
there and it's a healthy Zeke I think
that they were a team that needed a
little confidence they needed to see
Cole Beasley catch some passes and zing
gravity there Zeke to me wasn't really
and also it felt like they found an
identity choosing to run the ball with -
yeah if you don't think he's a hundred
and fifty million dollar quarterback
then don't be afraid to run him I also
think that the strength of the
Washington defense those two Alabama
guys get negated by the strength of the
Dallas off no doubt about it
yeah I look at this team and I go Tavon
Austin not a big deal I'm really hoping
the confidence is clicking for the
Cowboys and I look at Washington and I
think they were lucky to win that game
last week I think the Dallas defense is
really really good I would argue in some
cases it might be better than the
Carolina defense they just face oh it is
so I really like Dallas here especially
getting the points I think I would take
money line yeah I you listen I first of
all what you just said I'm gonna take
Dallas agate confidence I'm left go
[ __ ] lock but would you said about
the Dallas Cowboy defense I'm gonna give
you confidence there there's no doubt I
I would argue the Dallas's in that like
Dallas's defenses in the convo for
further than one of the best in the game
like they got everything now it's
official it's one of the best d lines
the fact that Byron Jones has panned out
a corner you know what's the injury did
is cheedo be a was a I did not see him
Bob well yeah just check that it's not a
huge blow if not because they have
enough cover corner guys to so it's not
a big deal the both of these defense
services are good he will place on he
will play that's a big deal because he
can lock people up man-to-man
both of these defense are extremely good
I have a hard time thinking the
Washington Redskins gonna be able to
push around this Dallas Cowboy defensive
line in any capacity really now I will
say the Washington offense is more
creative than Dallas there's no doubt
about that but this is not the kind of
game that you know they're not overly
creative to where I go oh no Dallas is
gonna have issues here no they're just a
little more creative than Dallas that's
not
a whole lot there okay and I think that
between Alec Smith his inability to
really throw the ball down the field and
throw any big-time power plays the
Redskins wide receivers are good but
they're not turning out to be quite as
good as I thought they were going to be
and they're banged up they're banged up
Gordon reads been inconsistent Paul
Burress Thompson is coming off of an
injury right
so those things concern me a little bit
this is a tough one to pick because I do
think that Washington yeah they're at
home they realize all the things you
said that Dallas has kind of had their
way with them I heard Jay Gruden in a
press conference yesterday we haven't
handled winning good in my career
actually we are better off a lot losses
than we are off of wins and I think his
record bears that out so they don't
handle success all that well but I think
what I saw for the Dallas Cowboys last
week puts me over the edge with them to
that there's just enough offense there
and they don't need a very complicated
formula I mean like we've been kind of
saying like if they just go Seattle
Russell Wilson Marshawn Lynch mode of
read option quarterback design runs a
few shots in the game bootlegs that's
Washington matchup in terms of stopping
Zeke yeah I don't know if they do
because as awesome as doron pain is
Jonathan's albums one of those tweener D
tackles so and he's not as good as your
mom pain Carrigan you line by pressing
Smith good
I do think Washington still missing
another real legit stud upfront for me
to go oh you're in the class of the
Cowboys the Jaguars the Ravens some of
those defenses I don't think I can put
them in that because of that out of the
fact that I don't think they can play
man-to-man on a consistent basis like
some of the other good defenses so
because of that think it's a really hard
football game
I'm putting $50 on the Dallas Cowboys
whoa
and I'm going I think they went 20 to 17
on the road last game of the four
o'clock slate here guys Wow one of the
guys moving pretty good
six ago LA Rams on the road visiting the
one in five San Francisco 49ers high of
77 in San Francisco on Sunday spread
it's really not San Francisco so you got
to go to Santa Clara
or spreading this game in San Francisco
I'll get you Santa Clara okay holy
ground and a half left go we'll go to
you first for the injuries in your pick
all right so Cooper covers out for the
Rams did not practice on Wednesday like
the fluster you Michael blockers and
Roger Saffold did not practice I think a
high of 76 sorry 1c Becca Greg Suhr line
is back for San Francisco Pierre Garcon
and Mike person did not practice Niners
are coming off a Monday night game I
believe this actually opened at the Rams
- 11 they're round a 9 and a half the
Rams are under Sean McVeigh as 11 point
favorites there - and OH since he's been
there right but the Rams the Niners
versus the Rams is actually very
interesting to me yeah you guys know how
much I love taking the Niners with a lot
of points right especially against a
Rams team that when I look at at their
schedule the last few games they have
not really been covering the spread they
didn't cover the spread against the
Broncos they left 20 points that up 31
to the Seahawks on the road they'll out
31 to the Vikings up 23 to the Chargers
and this is their third straight road
game now granted that they've been able
to spend those last three road games in
the upper Northwest I think there's a
huge advantage to them to go Seattle
Denver San Francisco it is but I will
say this
Niners last five is a double-digit
underdog for and one against the spread
now I know it's not double-digit anymore
last five against the Rams the Niners
are four and one and they're five and OH
against the spread Shaun McVeigh versus
Kyle Shanahan oh and two against the
spread hmm very interesting Rams have
not covered in their last three games
I'm going the Niners here for $50.00
I don't really feel I think the Rams are
the better team
I think I would like maybe Nick I do
like this song but I do wonder if we
could do like a little Wayne sound
effect from now on
alright just with Kyle Shanahan and the
Kyle father but I think that I think
that the Rams are gonna put up a lot of
points against the Niners at the same
point I look at the Niners and I know
they're on a short week and I was pretty
impressed with CJ Beathard and I know
they gave a lot of their effort I could
see them kind of slowing down after a
disheartening performance but it's a
divisional game against a team that's
getting a ton of praise right now and
the Rams allow themselves some deep
shots yeah and when I think about Kyle
against Wade Phillips he's he has done
some big things against him I mean as
the Thursday night game last year with
Brian frickin Hoyer he was putting up a
lot of points and then at the end of the
game the end of the year thinking about
the year at Wade Phillips was in Denver
and that defense was awesome and Kyle
was in Atlanta and they went into
Atlanta and beat them up they're right
remember the whole backs in the passing
game and all that stuff and the Niners
beat the Rams 34:13 the last game of the
year I know that was Jimmy Garoppolo and
the starters were in playing but I don't
know I like the liner
I like the Niners to cover the spread
nine and a half is too much I would have
rather this at six yeah I guess so it
opened up at 11 and a half 11 wow that's
that's a lot of points the Rams are cool
it's clearly the better football team I
mean let's let's not get it mixed up
there I think the cool thing about this
matchup too is you're talking about two
into the three best running teams in
football that's what's awesome okay I
mean the Rams are number one with 154
yards per game the San Francisco 49ers
are 100 are number three with 142 yards
per game defenses hey the Rams are
better the biggest reason the Rams are
better is their points allowed but it's
kind of skewed I think everybody's got
to realize that they played some crappy
offenses earlier in the year and took
advantage of that with as the Cardinals
and the shutout they got the Raiders and
only the Raiders are scored only thirty
thirteen points and you've seen lately
like you said Lefko is a lot of big
plays it really is and Kyle Shanahan's
run game
extremely hard to defend it's it's
special and I would have a hard time
thinking that they don't run the ball
again with some success against the rims
not that they're just gonna actually
absolutely blow their doors away but
it's gonna be concerning enough for the
Rams to go you know they're gonna be
vulnerable in the pass game behind that
I think if you look at the other side of
the ball - I just go okay that Rams
offense which is you know arguably the
best in football if if not it's it's top
three and against the 49ers defense
which hey the 49ers defense it's it's
off the couple little they do some
creative things they can confuse you
they really can now they can let up big
place - as we saw but I think as a whole
the 49ers defense has been encouraging
to me lately even the Chargers game you
know like it did take Aaron Rodgers four
or five drives to finally get the
game-winning like they did stop him the
often just couldn't get go exactly right
exactly right and I just have a hard
time thinking like you that the Rams are
gonna win this game by 10 plus points I
know it's a short week from the 49ers I
wanted to go hard like with the 49ers so
I went semi hard okay and I didn't mean
it to sound like that but I am going
$200 Wow on these San Francisco or Dena
is that the trolley got the trolley you
were singing San Diego super-short item
200 $200 I think the Rams are gonna win
this game 41 to 38 I think there's gonna
be a number of big plays and yeah I just
think at some point CJ Beathard will
screw up like he usually does late in
the game and the Rams will win the
football game
alright guys Sunday Night Football the
four and two Cincinnati Bengals on the
road visiting the five and one Kansas
City Chiefs high is 57 in Kansas City on
Sunday spread in this game is Kansas
City - 6 and lefke will go to you first
all right so did not practice for
Cincinnati after their heartbreaking
loss to the Steelers Giovanni Bernard
Billy price Nick a vigil dark has Denard
all did not practice on Wednesday
Eric Barry still out for Kansas City
just in Houston didn't
actus and Mitch Morse is still
recovering from a concussion they
brought in Jeff Allen to help out on the
offensive line he scares me when you're
picking up a guy off the street yeah but
Jeff Allen was with them for a while was
so I understand it the I am gonna be
putting $50 on Kansas City -6 I am NOT
that confident in this game because I
think that 6 is interesting and here's
why I'm not that confident here's why
I'm wrong last 15 times Kansas City has
been a favorite of six or more points
all under Andy Reid there are 4 and 11
against the spread there are 10 and 5
but they're 4 and 11 reason I feel like
I'm right Chiefs are 6 now against the
spread this season right best in the NFL
right so I'm not betting it against them
anytime soon
yeah also coming off a game like that
against the Patriots where they're gonna
feel good but they're also gonna go okay
now we know what it takes to be a champ
right and they're gonna be facing the
bengals the last for the big issue is
the bengals are historically bad on
Sunday Night Football huh since NBC took
over Sunday Night Football services
since 2006 the bengals are owen 7
they're 1 & 6 against the spread with
Andy Dalton they're Owen five on Sunday
Night Football
one in four against the spread right and
they've lost those five games with Andy
Dalton by an average of 11 point 2
points per game so they're losing by a
lot on Sunday Night Football now this is
the first Sunday Night Football for the
Bengals since November 2015 the Chiefs
on Sunday Night Football
3 & 1 straight up for know against the
spread I love Andy Reed on prime-time I
don't love Andy Dalton on prime-time
yeah and I look at the Chiefs and I look
at that offense and if Geno Atkins and
what's the guy's name
Andrew Billings Billings can really mess
up the interior the Chiefs offensive
line and get a lot of pressure on
Patrick mahomes I get it yeah but I look
at the Bengals and I know that they love
to go man a man and I cuz they are
athletic right am I wrong with that arm
oh no you're right you're right
you can't go man a man with this chief's
office and I think that the Chiefs go on
a scoring spree and I think that they
outpace the the Bengals at home on
something yeah the Bengals defense has
been it's weird
oh yeah it's disappointing really and
III don't even know what to attribute it
to their past Russia of course hasn't
been as good as as advertised
you know I know bonta's perfect is just
getting back into the flow of things I
really attribute it more than anything
in a schematic --all thats really what i
look at it they've been in this one
scheme for such a long time this Mike
Zimmer Paul Gunther scheme and now our
man Terrell Austin's there and Terrell
Austin's a little bit it's a totally
different language for them that's
really all I could chalk it up to
because I don't know what else to say
with teams like the Falcons the Panthers
made a lot of big plays on them even the
Ravens did and when they needed to in
that ugly game you know Pittsburgh of
course last week had their way in both
facets of the football game the Bengals
defense has just been disappointing I
don't know their best defense in the
Rams defense are kind of in the same
boat for me right now
you see a lot of talent but every week
they're allowing some big plays Rams
make plays at least though and cause
disruption every now and then and keep
you out of the end zone I think that's
where it's a little different I know
they haven't done it as much the last
two weeks I I don't know I have more
faith in the Rams because of Wade Wade
Phillips Phillips is just a little more
of a week-to-week change the game plan
kind of guy but neither one of these
defenses worth the damn I mean and
they're both not good at defending the
pass I mean the Bengals are 28 and
football in defending a pass to the
Chiefs are 31st and football I think
there should be a number of big plays in
this game I really do look at it that
way
I think gonna be a fun game to watch I
just think at the end of the day with
two bad defenses there's one offense
that is clearly better and that is the
Kansas City Chiefs we're seeing a
special thing here everybody so let's
just make sure we watch those we're
seeing a an offense in Kansas City they
can can do whatever they want you know
at the same time I'm betting $50 on the
Bengals I just think they're gonna score
points they're gonna
realize they got a score points and push
the envelope out there I don't think
they're gonna win the game but I'm going
$50 in the bangles I think the Chiefs
are gonna win 38 to 34 how dare you do
that to that little bangle like that how
dare how dare you do that so you think
the Chiefs win by four by four points
yes that's kind of what I picked I get
it yeah top one I mean I did this that's
why I built a night game that's why I'm
going $50 though because you know yeah
it's also Andy Dalton and company and I
always worry about that and I worried
that you know all the sudden Patrick
mahomes and company make like four
unbelievable plays if I go the game's 28
to 7 and then the pressures on the
pressures on Andy and it just look
freefall so yeah all right guys last
game of the week to break down here the
New York Giants at one in five on the
road visiting the Atlanta Falcons oh
really quickly is there any benefit to
the Chiefs playing at the exact same
time two weeks in a row there is two
playing Sunday Night Football them
playing Sunday Night Football
there definitely is yeah I mean just hey
they're creatures of habit you got a
feel for it last week it's gonna be a
similar routine again this week about
having to get up yeah two weeks in a row
though yeah it's again it's not it's not
easy but when you're on Sunday night
it's all air Monday Night Football
it's and you got the whole day of Sunday
to kind of lay around so I'm just like
an extra day a rest to a degree they're
gonna be ready to go there they're a
highly motivated team that believes in
themselves and I think they're gonna be
disappointed that they showed the whole
nation last week they lost the game in
New England that they feel like they
could have won gotcha all right Monday
Night Football
one in five Giants two and four Atlanta
Falcons in case you're curious I know
the game is indoors Sunday in Atlanta
63 and sunny just in case you were
wondering yup great cuz it gave us on
Monday sorry Monday Atlanta minus five
and a half is the spread there and left
go we'll go to you first for the injury
I don't have injuries because the game
on Monday so I'm gonna give you first a
little betting nugget yeah this came
from Joe Pikeville Pikeville USA Joey
Gunz
so there's his it's a betting system so
what you're doing is you're finding
trends right and the trend that's a
thing that he pointed out to me is the
host on Thursday Night Football the next
game they play
bet the over so it's a team that
typically has ten days of rest Athena's
11 days arrest when the team that hosts
Thursday Night Football plays their next
game but the over
thus far in a score point as far if you
bet the over five and oh oh okay that's
a good one joey gunz
so other than week - in which the Eagles
after playing on Thursday came back and
they still hit the over and they covered
by a half the cover the over is hitting
by an average of 25 points
more than the over/under right the
over/under this week for Giants Falcons
is 54 and a half so we're expecting a
game in the upper 20s to the lower 30s
if not more high and I think so it would
be on the over we have officially picked
up Eli Manning as our fantasy football
quarterback he's our fantasy quarterback
the Falcons
I can't believe I made this bet all of
the trends go to the Falcons yeah since
2015
Atlanta Monday Night Football is four no
three and one against the spread the
last ten Monday Night Football is for
the Giants three and seven the New York
Football Giants on primetime in the last
two years three and eight hmm but I'm
putting fifty dollars on the Giants to
cover the five and a half I think it's a
shootout I think that the Falcons
defense is worse than the Giants defense
I think that Eli and Odell have a few
big moments I think sake one
sake one might have 300 yards rushing
like and if not 300 he might have neat
damn near 400 all-purpose yards yeah I
think this is the a Giants team comes
together I could see them winning the
game and I just I think five and a half
is too high I think it's a shootout I
love in the point I think it's gonna
shoot a two I gotta think that the
Giants offense gonna put his best foot
forward I know I think Eli world
crashing right I gotta think Eli
Manning's officially hearing all this
noise and actually got to be thinking
like damn am I good anymore I gotta show
some people here the Falcons defense
thinks the Giants defense is better than
the Falcons defense and the Giants
biggest flaw has lately been their run
defense which is actually crazy I just
never thought that we were gonna say
that this year with some of the big
people they have but you know
everybody's kind of running on in the
last few weeks a little bit but I don't
think the Atlanta Falcons are good
enough in the run game themselves right
now to truly take advantage of that and
exploit the New York Giants
now the while that the Falcons in their
first seven games get five home games it
really is crazy now the New York giant
alibi yeah yeah yeah the New York Giants
past defense is okay certainly but we
know this Atlanta Falcons pass offense
it's real and they also know what that
their defense sucks and they have to
score points and I think Matty Ryan and
them know like if we don't score thirty
we have no chance of winning the
football game because of all those
points and the Giants are desperate in
that way and I know both are desperate
but like the Giants were embarrassed
last week with the extra game surviving
the Bucks exactly I'm going $50 in the
New York Giants - Wow let's go Josh I
mean it makes me feel like I'm sitting
in the mezzanine - 36 I guess pretty
quiet let's go Giants for me today yeah
I know yeah we got to do better I think
with the Giants and the New England we
have nothing for a new wing now they've
only won the Super Bowl
18 years in a row your Boston accent
right and you know so we got to do
better there we're better as a company
we can find something
Boston leggy junk [ __ ] Revolution
can't we figure something out and must
get solely crap going here Paul Revere
on his court out on his course
Nick Nick eg my recommendation would be
T how about them apples like taking that
audio he's see we're dealing with bias
here he just said he goes I hate Boston
yeah I get it
what an [ __ ] I refuse to be that type
of podcast we don't show bias Nicky Jay
alright so you and me right now we
agreed on a bunch yet you'll say I'm
gonna go through this we agreed on nine
and we disagreed on five and there's one
disagreement that's gonna completely
sweat he went you're besties over Brady
will do disagreements from this week
then we'll go to left go for the locks
and Sam's form you took on home you took
an away favorite in Chicago that's
that's where I'm going
after your disagreements in week seven
Thursday night football Sims is going
with the Broncos left go going with the
Cardinals I'm glad I like disagreeing on
Thursday Night Football with you
[Music]
Houston at Jacksonville Sims is going
with Houston left go is going with
Jacksonville loving it
so far I got two home teams moving on
down the schedule here in New England at
Chicago Sims has 600 bleacher bucks on
New England - three left go has a
hundred bleacher bucks on Chicago +33
home teams Detroit at Miami Sims has
Miami left go has Detroit you get a home
- and then the last disagreement of the
week is on Sunday Night Football Sims
going with Cincinnati plus six left go
you have KC - six I love it who are you
thinking about locking I would say right
now the leaders in the lock Clubhouse
are chargers - six and a half in London
against Tennessee Minnesota - three in
the New York Jets Stadium I would say
that Dallas plus two at Washington and
right now I am deciding between two
three games for my last lock and I'll
let you guys weigh in Carolina plus one
I haven't listened to anything you said
so the three lahiri locks the three
locks that I'm leading in the clubhouse
with I was writing down my GTS okay
sorry yeah welcome how's it feel how's
it feel
tell me tell me how they listen I just
interrupt how does it feel how's it feel
no you don't always listen either you
don't always listen sometimes and damn
you you killed a whole Brazilian forest
this week for your damn stats it's
disgusting are you done yeah okay
I'm the leaders the three locks I'm
definitely gonna lock our chargers - six
and a half in London against Tennessee
right Minnesota - 3 at the Jets Dallas
+2 at Washington and the thing that I'm
debating right now is am I gonna do
Carolina plus four and a half in
Philadelphia Baltimore - two and a half
at home and you kind of convinced me
with this San Francisco plus nine and a
half business I'm not doing New England
Chicago
you're not allowed me no I don't want
against our bleeeh our contracts so you
cannot do that now I think I'm gonna do
the Carolina one and publicly bet
against Philadelphia oh man what do you
think Carolina Baltimore San Francisco
Kate Carolina Baltimore or San Francisco
okay Carolina have you locked against
the Eagles yet this year
no they're all I think mmm
I think I'd probably go Carolina - yeah
I think so - I don't know I mean the
Baltimore one it's just too close
they're so even yeah the Saints are
dangerous it just scares me as far as a
lock is concerned the Rams scariest
thing about locking Chargers Tennessee
is that it's a 9:30 game so by the time
it gets washed into the I give you like
it could be they could be posting a
video of me locking the Chargers and
it's lost oh well we'll get it up early
I have a hard time thinking the 49ers
can lose by more than nine and a half I
know all right left go you know what
time it is right you want to look at my
teams ready you don't even care no dude
I'm always able to read the paper part
of the game part of the fun yeah buckle
that seat belt turn out that dial it's
time to get five teams that are
guaranteed slashed we're not really sure
if they're going to lose Sims last week
you went forward one good job holes in
the show holy crap first one we're going
across the pond a is that Big Ben no
because it could be a big L for the di
da Anna's right hello Titans you suck
last week and you're going to London and
you will suck again because the Chargers
are on fire and their offense is good
and man their defenses looking good -
Bruce let go told me Titans will lose
and I listen to Bruce he's smarter than
his son Adam all right he had a rookie
quarterback and he's not playing and
you're the guy that hasn't played in two
years
holy crap Derek Anderson starting and I
can't believe this but I'm picking them
guaranteed to lose against a team that's
only won one game but what uh what does
it come down to
ah hmm huh captain andrew luck is
greater than Derrick Anderson super
excited for those super excited for Sims
to figure this one out cuz he Rob he
wrote the wrong opponent for this game
oh I did I not write so well but I can
talk well that's what they pay me for
thank you hello Chicago yes Mike dick on
the burrs you've got Tommy Brady and
Billy ball game Belichick coming it down
it's October New England gets better
every week
Khalil Mack has a hurt ankle Brady's
gonna Pat the ball for nine minutes and
tear you apart hello Chicago welcome to
guaranteed to lose you're gonna lose you
know why cuz I said so Wow second glass
to you I'm guaranteed to lose a team
that simms bet on it's the old cross
prediction damn you're right I'm betting
on oh but damn they ain't gonna win cuz
they're not as good
sorry San Francisco you might be digging
for gold but you're not gonna find it
this week not on the Los Angeles Rams
watch I could tell you that you'll keep
it close but there's no consolation
prizes for keeping it close and
guaranteed to lose you're gonna lose
again sorry and the final team on
guaranteed to lose for week seven is
whoa ha ha ha the Cincinnati Bengals
nice but you can't beat Kansas City
Chiefs of Patrick mahomes in a shootout
an Arrowhead Stadium are you kidding me
this is my homey Patrick ma Holmes
bangles gonna lose my mama said so don't
mess with mama Luca booba de Dirty Diana
Sims have that was guaranteed to lose
brought to you by the new 17 piece
drumstick bucket only available at KFC
KFC we put the cholesterol into your
vade we're beans not beef route come on
come with something else
I said puts the cholesterol into your
vein as then you shouldn't eat it
because it's gross I will say though
growing up my parents would bring home
the bucket of KFC chicken yeah one of
the best nights tonight last time I ate
Kentucky Fried Chicken you pooped ever I
ended up on the toilet at a movie
theater sorry I love Kentucky I really
do my family's from there that is a
vicious visual oh man it was bad
thanks for sharing you know how long
that's been movie that was the movie
Crimson Tide Denzel Washington and Gene
Hackman I have all the boats yeah sorry
they call it a submarine these days it's
technically a boat that goes underwater
all right those are our picks let us
know what you think as always for Sims
peace out homies vendrick says good
evening everybody and for the lef koe
man
we will holler at you sunday is see on
the Internet's at sims Aleph go peace
[Music]